Good morning, folks. Quick uh 1-ish hour
stream this morning. Doing just a couple
little things for a client. Project
happens to be open source, so I figured
I may as well stream a bit.
And then this evening,
I'm gonna see what I do this evening. I
got a demo for a lab for Puffer. And
then um I might work on this more in the
evening. I might have some other client
stuff to do. We'll see.
I really do want to just have um 40
cranked out though at this point.
So this is uh archive. This is uh this
is open source. This is for a client.
This is a commerce marketplace sim
SIM is open source of course their
integrations and custom stuff is not
are aspects of Kimmy K2 can't at all
because I haven't seen it.
I don't follow LLM research man. I got
enough stuff to do without following LLM
research.
I'll tell you what, I'll solve the whole
rest of RL. They can solve um LLM RL
thing. Whatever.
By the time I get done working on like a
week's worth of stuff on this, I am
exhausted and I just want to chill for a
couple days. So, I'm uh mostly
refreshed.
Mostly
insert
mirror training. I'm trying to remember
what I did in this
I don't know what the heck I am doing.
There we go. Okay. So, uh I believe what
we wanted to do
first of all make sure this works and
then we will
Oops.
5090.
Node types. Oh, that should not be
there. That is awful.
Yeah, this needs to go down right here
so that I do not screw this thing up.
Three.
But my hands are it's for whatever
reason it is freezing in Florida. So
I've been wondering why like I've been
just so cold in my own room. I normally
do keep it cold. Like I'll keep it 65 or
68. I woke up this morning and it was 57
degrees in here. So
iguanas falling out of trees.
You know, I don't really see any
iguanas. We have little lizards, but
like it's kind of lame, right?
Let's see. So this is going to be plus
wait one two
quest nodes.
So do I add plus three? I think I do.
Oh, I know this, don't I? Isn't it 1
kilowatt?
All right. I did star quaries. Yes, I
did.
East coast or west coast? I'm in Florida
right now.
I spend some time in every year I spend
some time in Florida.
I spend some time in California and I
spend a bunch of time on the farm.
The farm is kind of just the best
though, at least for uh the months of
the year where it's like the weather is
at least reasonable.
I just get lots of training in. I get
lots of work done uninterrupted.
I really don't need um a lot of stuff to
do. I don't really get bored.
As long as I have some gym equipment and
some games to play and some cool
research to do, I'm good.
Oh, good question.
One moment.
Apparently I'm on the West Coast. Is
this where I am?
That doesn't look like where I am.
Apparently that is where I am. Huh.
So yeah, I'm literally several hundred
miles away from where I thought I was.
Isn't that great? I don't even know
where the [ __ ] I am.
Isn't that funny? I've come here a few
months every single uh every year. I
think I've looked that up a couple of
times. I don't even freaking remember.
asking irrelevant questions like where I
am and stuff.
Yeah,
it pretty much, you know.
Let me go look up what this guy asked me
to uh to make for him as a test. I think
he wanted something with we wanted like
a sanity check with like consumer
Get you extra tests. So, what did I
promise this guy
to each server and they'd be interested
in putting
bunch of 5090s
interested?
Okay. So
expected results.
So this should be a real that the point
of this is that you should give us some
real numbers, right?
trying to think what I want to do with
this.
90.
I think it's the fact that I don't have
um the cluster specs. Yeah. Node
capacity here.
It's a little jank, honestly. Like the
train setup is a little jank.
You kind of need multiple configs for
this project, which is annoying.
We can do Let me think what we can do to
get around this.
cluster spec
node capacity. Stay.
Is this only used on a nit cluster?
It's only used on a nit cluster. The
easiest thing to do,
I mean this is super gross but like you
see the issue here is that this whole
sim has to be stupidly configurable
and we have Python binding files and C.
So it's very difficult to not just
duplicate giant config crap.
I saw a post on two new contributors.
One of them did with vectorization.
So the thing that Peru did is he made it
um he put this demo in where
you can do multiple rollouts in parallel
which is very weird to me but it turns
out it's just faster. So it turns out
that you can have smaller forward pass
patches and then do multiple of them in
parallel. And that ends up using the CPU
better.
That was a very major contribution. And
it was cool because I would have never
come up with that. Like that's it was
very counterintuitive to me.
Uh what do we do?
Opacity, right?
Luster.
This is going to be nodes capacity.
Hello. Wait, cluster spec. Right.
So this is just going to be int node
capacity of node types.
Then we're going to do float node
capacity of node types. Good.
and then node.
Then the only place this actually gets
used is we do int
equals
there like that.
Okay. I miss doing this a lot. Like the
first like 20 minutes of this I was
like, "Oh, I could just use Claude for
this blah blah blah." But no, actually
just having the single line really
stupid model tab complete. This is so
much better.
Okay,
let's do um
I think that the only thing we have to
do is for this we assert these are
greater than zero and that's fine.
1590.
Uh, there should be
Uh, why does this not have 1590 price on
it?
Oh, wait. Why does this not have it
there?
Yeah, this should just be one one
0 0.
Why is this expected expression? Create
test spec
No.
Wait, what?
Am I being a goober? What' I do here?
Node capacity.
right, I'm looking. This is complete
goober. But what what the [ __ ] did I do
Oh.
Huh.
It needs to cast.
That's kind of jank.
Oh, no. I see why that is. Okay, I'm
dumb. No, no, no. That's legit. I'm just
dumb.
Uh, but that's going to screw us over. I
guarantee that's going to screw us over.
Oh, you know what we can do? I can do
size of int times uh num types
like this, right?
Then it's fine.
Not num types. Is it numbum nodes?
Node types
Well, that actually runs at the very
least.
So now what do we do? We do like a very
simple
5090 test case.
Now I just have to figure out what the
hell I've done here.
Uh, this is easy enough, right? So we
just do like this.
uh let's just do seller spec equals
cluster spec we'll just do node capacity
equals
uh node capacity dr is going to be zero
capacity
uh TB capacity DR this is zero this is
zero
wait kilowatt hour capacity
uh this is zero and this is zero
and actually this is a good test because
we'll see whether you need to be able to
be buying energy online, right?
20 40 20 40 20 40 20 40 20 40 20 40 20
40 20 40 20 40 20 40 20 40 30 minutes
this we'll get to um I got training to
get to today. I'm lazy this weekend.
Basically I streamed uh Wednesday,
Thursday, Friday I streamed a total no
Thursday, Friday, Saturday I streamed a
total of about 30 hours. I made Puffer
like 3 million SPS faster. I fixed a
bunch of crap and then I just crashed
for a day and a half.
Okay, buyer spec is zero.
AI buyers, AI sellers.
Oh, you just have one seller.
Yeah, this is totally fine, right?
This is totally fine.
I was gaming. Gaming was chill, Jess. we
didn't want to stream. Um, I am just
doing a little bit of client work. This
happens to be the open- source project.
So, I'm doing a little bit of this live
and then I'm going in 20 30 minutes. I'm
heading over to the gym for my training.
And then I've got a uh I got a demo
puffer for a lab
later in the afternoon real quick. And
uh then after that, I will probably be
back either working on this or working
on main puffer. We will see.
But little just little bit of work this
morning.
Get them a quick test.
Now, this is not working the way we
expected to, is it?
I have a sneaking suspicion.
Well, first of all, let's try. You know,
you you're lowballing, my guy. Let's try
Let's try this.
Okay. No, it's not this.
So, I think what's happening here?
I think I do have an actual bit of a
bug.
No, we actually are not checking here.
Um,
Exited.
Oh my guy. How did we not even get to
here?
That's super weird.
They not run.
Oh, wait.
Yeah. So, we can't have it just generate
uh job nodes like this.
Yeah. So, we're going to do this real
quick.
And we got to go job nodes.
Did this not recompile? What the hell?
No, it just literally didn't save. Okay,
I already did that. I'm not that dumb.
Okay, nice.
So,
so we have 100.
So, wait. Episode length is 100.
Okay. So, let me think if this makes
sense. So, it's 100 hours worth of
rentals.
So it should be the upper cap should be
you have um times 0.37
We say it's nine. So the inter the
medium value it should be four.
That correct?
Let's stop lowballing him a little bit.
Oh, we want to be the uh we want to be
the seller here, don't we?
So, it should be AI buyer should be one.
Let me think. Wait, what time do I have
to leave?
Cuz I basically what I want to do is I
want this thing to match um like the
expected real world value of this thing
roughly and then I can send this over as
a nice test. We'll be set. Prediction
market. It's not a prediction market
like that's the those are gambling. Um,
this is this is just like a straight
simulator that you can run RL on.
So, prediction market would be for
arbitrage. This would be for like
actually running the thing.
How the end works.
Um, well, I mean, it's just it's a
simulator where you have a bunch of
machines on a market and then you can
either have the RL agent buy the
machines or sell the machines or both.
And then you can plug in scripted
opponents. It's an industry sim, right?
This is what's this? 700 lines for the
base sim plus a few hundred lines worth
of tests. Um, so I mean this is for a
client. It's online. You know, this is
why I can stream it.
Uh, do they have the Do they have it on
here yet? Well, they do have it on
GitHub, but it's these guys. Oh, yeah.
Here it is. GitHub
and repos.
There you go.
So, it is on here. You can go check
their stuff out.
why they pay if it's going to be open
source. I mean, because obviously
there's a whole bunch of additional work
for integrations and stuff. And the
benefit of having it open source is that
they can just like they can have people
try to train better agents for them,
right? They can use it for hiring. It's
the same thing like why do people pay me
if puffer is open source.
Clients are not required to open source
their environments. They just decided
to.
Plus, they get some extras, right? Like,
hey, I can stream this as well. They get
a couple more eyes on it. Maybe a couple
of you all decide, oh, this is a cool
environment. Let's see if I can get some
better agents or whatever.
Trying to see what
we probably should have like a verbose
mode for this thing.
Okay. I mean, this is what we would
expect, right?
I bet they have very short duration.
Yeah, that's
This is still very odd.
What if I do this?
They rent servers. I think that they're
probably trying to like negotiate use of
their stuff with compute providers
directly.
I don't know. If I speculate too much,
then we're getting going to get into NDA
territory. So, I mean, what I can tell
you is it's a compute marketplace sim.
They're doing some pretty cool stuff
with compute marketplaces. And uh it
turns out that it's a problem where we
can RL it.
Yeah, our scripted opponents are super
dumb as well, Jess. It's just a basic
sanity check.
So, you know, this ends up just being a
nice problem
for RL
200x single. Yeah, we're expecting
double this profit though. So, what is
going on here?
I'm seeing
lots of jobs being accepted.
This is the energy expense.
Oh yeah. Do we recognize the whole
revenue up front now? I think we do,
right?
Oh, yeah. These expenses are insane.
Buyer expense.
Yeah, that doesn't make any sense at
all.
Oh no, because this is the buyer side.
Yeah. So the buyer side rev is a little
weird.
Well, this is weird, right?
What problem are we solving with puffer
in this case? The pricing.
What are we logging for profit
and log profit? Lovely
job profit. So we get job revenue
minus job expense
How does this make any bloody sense
then?
This is more than 100.
Why do I have more than a hundred of
these?
Oh, because you do lobsties, dummy.
I see.
Ah, interesting. So, something is
getting screwed up here then.
Interesting. So, I got to finish this.
I'm going to probably do this then in
the afternoon today
is what I'll do. We'll get this test
working. And then the goal will be that
this is like this basically resembles
the type of revenue you would expect to
have if you were selling 25090s
and then I'll send this over to them and
they'll be nice and happy. I'll work on
this later today. Um, and then if I
finish that this afternoon, then maybe
we'll do evening stream on Puffer again.
Tomorrow is all day puffer dev.
Barring any weird stuff happening,
I'm getting to the gym. Thank you folks
for tuning in. If you're interested in
my stuff generally, puffer.ai for all
the things, start the GitHub really
helps us out. It's rounding up to 5K
right now. I'd like to get to 5K flat.
Join Discord to get involved. Follow on
X for more content. Thank y'all.